- [Voiceover] They dance, they
flail, they're a big wacky
and awkward way to get your attention.
But did you know these Tall Boys debuted
at the 1996 Olympics, as art?
(lighthearted Caribbean music)
Meet Peter Minshall, a
prominent Caribbean artist.
Known in Trinidad as the
creator of larger than life
dancing puppets created for Carnival.
His work made its way to a book called
Caribbean Festival Arts.
And that book made its way to a man.
A man on the steering
committee of the Olympics.
Peter was commissioned to
help create an unforgettable
opening for the 1996
Olympic games in Atlanta.
In a moment nothing short of pure genius,
Peter returned to his roots by sketching
a puppet-like structure
but this time he turned it
into an inflatable air-man
that would move and dance
just like his manned-puppets.
For this he had to call in another artist,
Doron Gazit, an engineer
who happened to be obsessed
with anything inflatable.
Between both men they
were able to accomplish
the seemingly impossible:
60 foot inflatable two-legged dancing men.
The Tall Boys were nothing
short of a success.
After they graced the
Olympics, Gazit got a patent
and licensed the design
to various advertisers.
Now they're everywhere.
Used car lots, cropped
fields, shopping centers,
you name it.
So the next time you see a big
ridiculous inflated Tall Boy
waving at you in the distance,
just imagine you're in the Caribbean
dancing along to the drum beat.
(lighthearted Caribbean music)